the next speaker i'm bringing up
he was the youngest heavyweight champion
of the world he was known
as the most feared man on the planet
on top of that he later on
featured in a documentary that millions
watched some call it a movie that
documentary was called hangover with
that being said give it up to the one
the only mike tyson
[Applause]
[Music]
they love you mike
awesome
well i didn't expect to see you either
grab seats grab seats grab seats so
how you feeling mike how you doing feel
great yes first of all appreciate you
for coming out
agreeing to do this i'm really
overwhelming that i had never
anticipated this well they've been
looking forward to seeing you for quite
some time now i think i want to start
off with something
a bit of a more you know uh technical
question for maybe more of a serious
question to start off the uh interview
with
how was it being in the movie hangover
yeah
my time man you had a good time as soon
as he put me in that movie i want to be
in number two now would be the next one
i almost threatened the director
what was zach's reaction when but did he
actually like did you actually hit him
did you actually hey man watch the
puncher because that's really like kind
of a tough guy in real life
just watch it with the punches okay
exactly yeah
anybody see it hang over yes or no yes
okay so in the back we're talking mike
and i are talking i i was telling mike i
said mike how do you how do you view
competition like when you think about
the word competition what does that mean
to you i think if competition is people
um reaching their highest potential they
have a potential they have the potential
to reach to reach their highest
potential when competition comes
competition is always good because it
helps you not to give in under the
slightest struggle in life
because life is gonna life is gonna give
everybody a bad hand no one's gonna
leave here um without being tried in
life wow and you have to be you know
you're gonna have to take it like what
they say um adversity make the strong
stronger the weak weaker
so so to you competition's inevitable
you can't avoid competition
right this minute
i'm competing with my wife
write this man i'm competing with my
wife if i'm gonna get home early enough
or not
but everything to you in life you see it
as a competition
everything has to be competition is
great it builds character and it gives
you backbone you don't have to give in
as i was saying earlier and the
slightest struggle some people like
nowadays it's like the um
everybody's um
believed that someone should give them
something yeah everybody nobody wants to
work now
anybody but special kids that have
wealthy parents like myself they don't
most of them don't want to do what they
should do
so how do you deal with that
then we're going to take then we got to
go to trust funds
we
if you don't do this you don't get this
[Laughter]
right if you don't do this you won't get
this does it work oh it worked for
century
that's got to be a counter that's what
competition is all about
someone has to be number one once they
have a letter like everybody in the
family everybody in their family know
who's the strongest one in the family
who's the matriarch
even if they're older they can kick his
ass they know he's the boss and she's
the boss
right
that doesn't have nothing to do with
strength and being big they know who the
boss is they know who can run the house
they know who the yes no it's not the
boss he distinguished himself or she
distinguished himself
out of all of us that's why we know
they're the boss even though we're older
than them
[Music]
why why do you think so many people
today don't like competition they're
almost like either sensitive to it or
they say it's not a good thing like why
do you think that's happening
i don't know i know i just don't know
people believe um
entitlement that's the word i was
looking for
a lot of people entitlement some of my
kids too they're entitled
they think their bank account should be
full because you're the still
that's just what they think you know i
did this all this for them but they have
to they have to match me you know maybe
you're making 200 bucks
you got 200 bucks a month whatever you
have i'll match that but i'm not going
to give you something that you never
worked for you don't know exactly he
don't know the cause of the struggle for
it
so without him knowing the struggle for
it he'll give it up very easily
coming up when you're coming up in the
in the streets of new york when you're
coming up what was it like what was it
like trying to make it out of the
streets of new york and making your own
money how about it it looked impossible
that was gonna never happen i never even
dreamed about getting out of new york i
dreamed about living there
robbing and stealing and dying in the
same block i was born on wow had no idea
this was going to happen
what changed what i went to a place
called spars it's like a
correctional center
and my and we watched the movie the
greatest like 78 77 like 11
12.
and they turned on the lights and
muhammad ali came in and for some
strange reasons i want to be like him
as soon as i left it i went to another
place
and um
it was the guy that was an xbox and he
told me how to box and that's why i'm
here with you
so before that were you a street fighter
like were you brawler all the time all
the time money yes what does that mean
all the time for money i must have like
three fights four fights a day
for money money i was robbing somebody
but walk us through like your day was
like
walk us through it like are you talking
like kimbo slice like they're fighting
in the streets or just right yeah
so before there was a kimbo you were
fighting in the streets no everyone did
that everyone there it kimbo did that's
what everyone did but they did it
numerous times you did it in this
neighborhood you did it in that
neighborhood and that neighborhood every
night you went through you did it
so you already had a reputation building
the street yes yes yeah and were you a
knockout artist with yes
yes
when when when you were coming up did
you ever like your time at 12 13 14
years old fighting
no i'm talking about like from 9 10 11.
[Applause]
by the way just curious he's gonna say
um this stuff is came natural
9 10 11 that's what i was made to do
i'm not alive i'm like baby huey
so you didn't know your own strength now
now once you realize like you are
stronger than the average human being
you're all of the tough guys and the
criminal guys want to hang out with me
then they put me in that gang now i can
be in that gang
they always say get him snatch that word
snatch his watch snatch his purse snatch
this snatch that and that's what our
crew was about
did you ever fight somebody that you
were like that they got you was there
ever a kid that got you or not
absolutely
in order to be good you have to lose and
understand loss
because loss is life
was there anyone you fought in the
streets that meets you that later on
became a professional boxer
some of them became drugged us someone
became
um i
in my name but these guys don't they
don't get the
opportunity to get these
blue collar jobs and stuff when you were
coming up at 9 10 11 did you have a
nickname like did they dirty ike dirty
ike yeah
why dirty ike
because even though i had nice clothes
they were always dirty
is that why yes
i had no idea about hygiene i'm nine
years old and i have let's say if i'm
nine years old and i got 5500 bucks on
me i don't know nothing behind i know to
buy the clothes and stuff because i see
my friend and they taught me that but i
go and then i go to my pigeon coop and i
got [ __ ] on the clothes and everything
i i had no idea about hygiene i just
knew the representation of clothes were
good i didn't know i had to clean them
so let me go back
you just kind of said it very solid any
one of you guys ever at nine years old
had fifty five hundred bucks in your
pocket yeah i'm nine years old oh um you
said you had fifty five hundred people
rob people's houses and in people's
houses you get everything we had god no
listen
no
you have to hear this
since everybody's here you want to talk
you can't play we robbing these we got
guns we only 10 11 years old we got
automatic guns we got 45.
man it's just crazy
you ain't going in these people
i never knew that i thought you got
through everybody house looked like mine
shitty with roaches and all that going
in wow
wow
nine years old nine ten eleven nine ten
so so now go go eleven twelve thirteen
what happens next so again get arrested
and i see muhammad ali come to the visit
into institution that i'm in
and that and i saw him and i got turned
out
i don't know how to happen in the spirit
boom i want to be like him you said
you're in jail and ali shows up i'm 12
years old and ali comes in he and they
showed the movie the greatest first so
this is 77 and um
after the movie the lights come up and
ali comes in and i see him i want to be
just like him
and then i get transferred from the
playstation muhammad ali to this other
facility you know for real bad kids
and um
i met a gentleman there that was a boxer
and he used to teach me how to box and
one day i broke his nose right and um
he got mad i didn't know he was mad but
he's mad that his wife didn't want him
to box me no more and that's why he was
mad so he took me to a great trainer
named customato and that's why i'm here
when you saw ali did you speak with him
was it like oh no
boom wow
that won't be like him unfreaking
believable story so your inspiration
happened at 12 years old yeah then you
meet cass yes how was cuss treating you
what happened for you to be loyal what
was his way of leading you
yes a degree of just peeling
all that dirt and stuff that insecurity
and
um
developing into character
and um
that's why i had a wonderful time with
him with everything about
everything about his life was about me
and so i never had a father but um i
know what it's like to want to make a
father happy and so i wanted to be
champion to make him happy but you said
peeling so that process a lot of us have
oh listen i don't know because when i
first came there i wanted to rob the
place
no when i figured that's that's my life
that's what i'm about
so when i first came in this is a man's
eye this old victoria imagine i said wow
you know i said what could be in their
drawers you know
that's just how my mind think even now i
have millions of my mind still thinks
that way but um
and i didn't know because he at that
time i didn't have any self-esteem any
character and he would always saying
look in the mirror look how handsome you
are today so i thought he was a
homosexual that was hitting on me or
something but i don't know he was just
building my characters allowing me to
love myself and um
we just had a great relationship for
several years um
i won a bunch of championships across
national championships he got me very um
worldwide known
and um i carried his legacy
was he was he somebody that would uh was
he direct with you would he be around
the boat nothing straight to you no
[ __ ] so give me an example like how
would he talk to you
um
you don't want to be champ you're a
tomato can you don't want to work
you you sound like that in here but i
cried if you say that to me because
tomato came to me
it's not like it's funny to you but
tomato can't mean
anybody's willing to blow you over you
ain't [ __ ]
i got you so he was not one that would
be like you're amazing mike you're such
a sweetheart you're going to be he was
no
um after i'm getting like um i'm on the
front cover of sports illustrator right
after i'm talking to us i'm getting
friendly with the reporters and
everything and the girls have my makeup
like i'm somebody and then they said
take the broom i'm off and clean the gym
he told you that yeah all the lights on
me like everybody see me i'm all
cocky and stuff i'm on the front cover
of sports illustrated um don't forget
the broom and mop mic
everything's humility
wow
i mean i've experienced that person with
a lot of people in the company yeah i
mean that's amazing make some noise guys
so
in your opinion
those who make it at the level that you
made it i mean the level that you make
it there's seven billion people in the
world that you're number one so it's not
like you're one in a hundred you're one
in a thousand it's one in seven billion
when you made it as a boxer at that
level do you notice a common trend like
right now i think it was mackie put up a
quote from michael jordan michael jordan
my biggest strength was
i'm coachable i'm a sponge i want to
learn i want to get better do you notice
the level at the highest level is
similar to somebody challenges pushes to
see that that person wants it or not
i guess um it's cool that people are
seekers i think that's very interesting
that we're seekers but we have to
believe that we're divine and that we
learn from our experience because um
confidence breeds success and success
breeds confidence they go hand to hand
you can't accomplish anything unless you
say oh i'm a prick i could never do that
i'm not born to do that only certain
people go anyway people could do that i
can't do that
there's nothing i can't do you know you
may just be canceled after what you just
said right now oh man you can't say
something like that white people can
only do it because you and i i'm iranian
you're black we can't say thank you i
don't care i don't i don't care about
i got my own plane
whew
[Applause]
i don't care if you get mad i don't care
you don't let me on this plane in his
boat
[Laughter]
going back to cuss going back to cut so
cuss had also done it in the past before
right like a custom knew how to develop
people right he had a reputation for
developing people did you ever see
anybody that he worked with that they
just couldn't take it and they quit
working with cuss like some people just
emotionally couldn't handle that kind of
pressure no cuss knows when to put the
gas on when put the brakes on
you know that's what a teacher does he's
a teacher we all
teach everyone all of us teach everyone
all teachers and students this world is
one big school and we're the students of
this world so he would he knew timing
and he knew
uh when when to motivate and what not to
motivate absolutely
he knows the mind is always hungry and
the mind wants to do good but we get so
many
negative thoughts in our minds almost
overwhelming to be positive so mike you
have to know this is so important
because you're like an encyclopedia in
this area because you work with the best
and you become the best so i'm trying to
extract as much information from you as
possible in this so would you say for
him when you were cocky he humbled you
when you were down he built you up would
you say it was like a timing thing with
them
no it was no game you know um
there's so much power and
humbleness you know when i'm when i'm
promoting the fight i say outrageous
things and stuff but i know the power of
humbleness now how did you learn that i
have to lose everything
got it
got it well now you got to get a lot of
it back by the way you got some i mean
you know you don't want people know you
got money means nothing
once you listen
if you think a lot of money could make
you happy
you never had a lot of money before
so what do you value now what's at the
top for you to value me my children my
whole
barometer of life
listen
listen i've been down and up down and up
broken up and why am i still here
talking to these guys why you guys
paying me to talk to y'all
why did we do it guys i've been in
prison a bunch of times i don't
i don't kick some people's ass on
television and call people white [ __ ]
hunky and listen um
and the reason i'm still here is because
i understand what humbleness is you know
i understand humbleness and um
i think sometimes god doesn't like me
because he knows i can't handle this
[ __ ]
i'm serious he knows i can't handle this
no i got a label on me i'm the best
fighter i gotta i have to i i'm um i
have to conduct myself in a certain way
that's what my wife tells me now she
tells you that you have to conduct with
something certainly
what do you think about that yeah you
have no more difficulties you can't go
to the clubs no more oh yeah that's what
you know they want to control your life
they better control your life how do you
handle that like you can't go to the
club i mean that's just too many
restrictions go to the class you don't
have to the club
is it weighing it out saying club's wife
what's more important
i i can go to the club i just don't want
to come back and see you after i went to
the club
you know you know when they look at you
and you want to say what the what did i
do i hit for an hour
listen
my wife don't think i know she put
she put a tracker on my knees she got me
a new truck and have a tracker on it
right in the lock my right hand my wife
do you know that or you don't know that
oh i know now
[Applause]
why did she do that with a track on the
car
so what do you do are you strategic you
go park it somewhere call an uber and go
through the club or no i don't need
driving when she's in it
[Laughter]
let's go back to it so mike you're
coming up
cuss is working with you he trains you
and then all of a sudden you start
fighting at what point did you know that
you could be the heavyweight champion
like you got to fight you got two fights
you got three fights
14 years old you knew you were going to
have to be the champion before you
become the champion so that means
lifestyle
after being before you become
you got to be him before you become him
unpack that
um you have to live his lifestyle the
lifestyle of a champion i'm the champion
you look at the champion
that's how it starts you look at
somebody i want to be like him
you don't say hey i'm a bad [ __ ]
i want to fight everybody out here
nobody's going to take my ass you see
somebody and say hey i might want to do
that
so inspiration the source of inspiration
so is that what got you to be uh willing
to be disciplined to get what you want
like to become a champion at 14 years
i'm willing to do everything it takes to
be a champion absolutely and then i had
cuss over there telling me why why
should he have it
that's one thing i never had in my life
being because i always got picked on and
i never had jealousy or enviness about
anything and cuss possessed that
you know and he was telling me why
should he have all that money and you
don't why is he why
why why do you believe that he's better
than you why do you think he should have
all that money you don't and he was
really serious about it
and that's with the competition [ __ ]
that's the right thing breathing that
stuff right in me
why should he have and he's not better
than you how did you handle that when he
told you that 14.
would it piss you off were you like i'm
going to go trying to whoop his ass i'm
going to get there one day what was that
what was your response to it he said one
day oh god i can't taste this guy know
how to really get in my head he said man
you're fighting good but i wish you were
bigger he said i wish you were like
kenny norton uh another there's another
guy mike mike weaver because they had
big bodies and they could intimidate
somebody and that hurt my feet i said i
make sure the whole world's gonna be
afraid of me
he he laughed but that's what i said
so he knew how to poke you oh yeah
did it piss you off are you like i'm
gonna prove you wrong type of thing i
better not you know i better act like
i'm upset and mad at him yes sir
i'll do better why if you did what would
happen yes you know you just don't talk
to me you know what i'm telling you
don't talk to him like that's your
teacher are you worried that he may take
time and spend time with somebody else
instead of you or is it just kind of
like i respect the teacher i want to
listen to you i want i want him to be
satisfied with my work i want to say you
look beautiful today like he said when
he first said when he first said it to
me and i thought he was a weirdo i
wanted to say it again
i wanted to say now i don't know he's a
weirdo and i know he's not weird i want
to say he loves me again
how much of what he did to you
do you do to your kids and others listen
i wouldn't dare do to my kids what he
did to me why is that baby
um i could because um
you some some guys listen
this is the real deal
if i don't do well in boxing i go to
prison or i die if my kids don't do well
they go back to a big house and all
their rich friends come over and they
play eat stuff and get that come on it's
not the same how do you create that
pressure for them how do you create that
can you actually create that kind of
intensity and pressure or no by the time
i'm sending a military school if you got
to pick a sport
so you're going to send them to military
schools
these kids don't want to get tough
enough they might have a heart attack
nowadays
how do you do that how you actually do
that is is it even possible in your mind
to pass down that toughness to someone
else
well listen you can always be tough but
even though i don't care how much money
you got some guy money got how
successful you are and you may not like
him he did wrong you're never better
than your father
why is that it's just just the way god
made it
it's just the way man i don't care how
much money i have how much my father
would kick my ass my father would kill
me
we're not our fathers
go a little deeper with that that's a
pretty deep comment oh it's just that my
father's a real serious guy i don't i
would never want to have a qualification
with him this is who's your father this
is you're talking about
this my um biological okay i got you wow
so to you know even as a champion of the
world i have people my body's got a crew
i'm still a little area of him he was
just that kind of guy he's killed people
he's done bad stuff
he was just that kind of guy so your dad
was feared by others he was an
interesting guy he's a preacher
he's a preacher
okay
he's a preacher now no he he's always
been in the church he's born in the
church raising church preacher deacon
preacher yeah listen mean [ __ ]
i mean i bet a hundred percent of people
got baptized i swear to god if you don't
get baptized i'm gonna take you out
afterwards was it like that or oh no
listen they don't play my family the
religious the christian side they don't
[ __ ] around
they're all articulate they're going to
go to ivy's they're very intelligent but
yes they're physical
what's what's your style of parenting
your kids now what's your style of
parenting them
is it okay so give me some of the values
responsibility
listen
sometimes um
you're not going to go on the plane that
you're by yourself they said when are we
going to go back on the plane where it's
just only us no because you didn't do
really good today
that's just how it is you know sometimes
you got to know it never fails when you
take something away from somebody that
once they possessed it and fell in love
with it and take it away
i like doing that too you know once you
take something away people um hey they
get on their p's and kids quick right
yeah they do the crying see the crying's
not going to work i love you dad
to to to be able to do that also takes a
little bit of knowing that you got to
challenge this person to improve their
character long term hey listen right i
have a night no no i have a 24 year old
son right yeah and every now and then i
see him he tries to wrestle with me he's
bigger than me but he wrestles with me
and i tell him to get your [ __ ] hands
off me
i know what's in his mind i know it's in
his mind don't let him play with me like
that
are you joking with them or you're dead
or you're dancing
i mean i'm sure if somebody was your son
telling you get your hands off me they
gotta they gotta listen to you well
listen
you listen somebody this is listen
for some reason when a young kid
feels that his mother they're not
together they feel even if they're
together he feels that his mother they
they challenge you for their mother love
any kind of way if you're sleeping with
them they want to get in the middle and
their babies the next thing that you
have an argument they want a defender
and challenge you it's all about that
connection with them they feel they have
to protect their mother
and i said you can't be mad at that so
you got to go you got to pick your
battles that's all that's what i'm
saying so i learned to do that i don't
know how to do that i learned how to
bend what i've learned so far is rule
number one
avoid the clubs that's number one right
and avoid nightclubs i don't think
that's her rule that's her rule that's
not true
responsibility
takes things away when you give it to
him well i was just just admiring my
relationship my house i can't do
anything you yeah
for you know
nightlife
so so boxing you're coming up you're
coming up at 14 you know you're going to
be a champion during that time
whatever's cost telling you you're doing
it you're not questioning you're fully
coachable to him you're committed to him
you believe he can help you become a
champion yeah what is your training
during that process yeah i'm losing too
i'm getting beat i'm getting knocked out
i'm never getting discouraged though
what does he tell you after you lose
does he talk to you what does he tell
you after you lost like well you know
normally
when i lose i look so spectacular he
said they told me that you're moving
because i'm i have five or six fights
i'm fighting guys with 100 fights with
60 fights and i'm knocking them out and
they're grown men and i'm just 14 years
old so because this guy beat me right by
decision he's 25 years old and cuss came
to me
like um i'm some little baby i'm just
like hey i heard he was too smart for
him but you beat him to this
i'm a ninth grade
the technical aspect of boxing did you
get that from him or were you because
when you talk boxing like i know you're
a big durant fan you're very much of a
technical guy when it comes to listen
once i'm involved in something i want to
know the beginning of i want to know
where it came from how it was started
who's the first guy that invented it
that's just how my mind works
yeah i've seen you i've seen you train a
couple of the guys you would talk about
footwork you would talk about how to
punch him here how quickly you go below
to go there
and you sound like a mathematician when
you're talking about the art of boxing
yeah i'm
i was born for it
you were born for you were born to fight
nine nine years old you're bullying
twenty year olds i mean that's pretty
impressive right there i was yeah i was
very impressive young man hey but i was
just sad that 12 years old everybody
thought i was going to be tall
wait you were deciding oh this sounds
200 pounds or 12 years old
i would listen
i was fighting the kids that would fight
out fighting their fathers
no i'm serious i would fight their
father i was fighting their fathers
what do you mean you were fighting their
fathers like i might have passed
somebody and i hit them too hard even
crying went home and got his father and
then you would do the
the truth
there's people out here that have been
in that world they know what time it is
they know there's people out there that
are animals they're little babies
because their family were that way have
i had violent family me my family was
violent and i'm violent
is it still in you or it's left you hey
when i needed to come back when you
needed a counselor
how many guys watched the roy jones
fight anybody watching roy jones fight
yes or no by the way you look really
good in that fight with i was just happy
that being to be able to entertain
people and i gave that to charity
yeah but but mike with all seriousness
like you look like you you could hang
with a lot of the younger guys right now
that are boxing you don't look like you
were struggling in there i don't know i
like to push myself so this time i tried
lennox lewis
you want to go it's linux lewis this
time
and then if this go well
i'm gonna push myself deeper oh
i don't know maybe
tyson fury he told me if i keep
wondering i'm gonna do good here boy man
i sent fury yeah that's my buddy no i
know you guys are buddies i've seen he's
been on your podcast you guys have done
stuff together but you'd fight tyson
fury
hey i fight a lion if the price is right
if the price is right yeah you get in
the ring with a line cage match with a
lion i'm just hey listen i just can't
help it i'm a glory freak i think yeah
you would fight along anything you know
i raised lions
no of course we know that we watch
hangover yeah
actually i had um five lines around 11
tigers before
you had a white one was it was there a
couple of white couple of white ones
yeah it's what is it with you with lines
tigers and pigeons
listen
so listen i'm in prison
i'm talking to my mechanic
and so my mechanic has some of my cars
he's holding my cars and he's mad at one
of my friends so he said devonte don't
give me my money back i'ma trade some of
his cars in for some animals like some
horses i said what do you mean you could
trade some you got some animals he said
yeah this guy they had tigers and mines
i said what you mean cubs he said yeah
white tigers and white lions too and so
i'm in prince by the time i get home
from prison i got two lion cubs like two
white
um tiger cubs on my lawn
how was i like how big did they get with
you well they have to be 400 pounds
i mean i've seen you walk around when
you were young i sleep with them
you sleep with lions
tightly yeah you prefer tigers over line
i prefer lying though
for lions over time
so they sleep in your bed
yeah
only one at a time with two in their
fight
that kind of sounds strange what you
just said right there you know
you're vegas when you say things like
that it's yeah no because i was on on
one day i was on one of my
um who was the lady and what's the name
but anyway i was being injured i said i
want to breed her and have babies with
her but they look like i wanted to
breathe in the way i said well i want to
breathe and have babies when they say
mike what do you mean you want to
breathe
i'm not good with words
sleeping next to a tiger when they roll
over did they ever roll over you 400
pounds or what was it like i mean are
they like putting their arms around you
are they
hurrying in the morning control
themselves they control their weight
they know they're balanced they're very
agile
they could know what the tiger he could
do i take him around full speed ahead
and run up the wall and come back down
in the seats
come back under his feet
you want to sleep
no huh and you want to sleep with him
i'm the one that brought him out of his
mother
yeah i want to sleep got it and the
relationship with the pigeons
that i'm curious with the pigeon story
that's just something i've been doing
all my life you're you're entitled to
explain that is that a new york thing is
that a mop thing did you get closer to
mom because bob always had pigeons like
were you connected to the gangsters a
little bit listen
that's interesting most gang that's a
gangster thing because when i went to
moscow and i was actually you know the
the biggest pigeon fans here and it was
all the mob guys these guys the pigeon
crews are as big as this like houses
and they had acres the the property as
far as your eyes can see i'm saying
these are not normal people
yes yes it just wasn't so yeah you're
right they do a lot of them lots of
pictures you have pictures yeah i don't
know what maybe it's a messenger it's
like maybe it's back in the day so it
was their way of sending emails
he had pigeons too two of them yeah
mommy let him out and he got to see you
had kidneys too
you're 14 to 21. yes it's training you
no 14 to 19.
i'm sorry 14 to 19. what's the training
looking like how hard are you training
during that time i'm doing everything
first day in the morning three in the
morning you do your four miles come back
three in the morning yeah
do your four miles come back and do your
body exercise and all that stuff get in
the hot tub
go to bed i might watch some fight films
i watch a lot of fight films that's why
i'm very
um
acute with most of the [ __ ] oh yeah so
after that i go after the breakfast
go to the school
come back from school
eat my
food um then i go back to the gym at six
o'clock train come back at eight o'clock
um watch fights start all over again
i do a lot of chance i do a lot my most
of my gym work and i watch movies that's
the most part of my life which which
fight was it where you
were most excited about when you won it
was it the one where you became the
heavyweight like if you go back and say
my favorite fight when i won was this
one what was it larry holmes larry
holmes yes is that because what uh ali
whispered to you when uh because he beat
ali up real bad and i was on the phone
cussing new alley so i talked out later
the day after the fighting for homes
and because i have this young black
kitty lovely channel i want you to talk
to him and i'm crying him on the phone
he said i'm gonna be back and i'm gonna
fight homes again i'm gonna knock him on
and i'm crying when i get big i'm going
to get him for you and he must be hey
kid you know who i am the greatest of
all time this and this that and that but
that's what i based my life that's my
job with to get larry holmes
for ali yeah that's my whole purpose in
life
wow
was it was there a rage like when you
fight against homes was it like i'm
gonna destroy you yeah
i knew i had to
yeah because you seemed angry in that
fight yeah i had to
he's a great fighter i'm a great admirer
of larry holmes too he's a magnificent
fighter but it was just that thing
when i saw that he beat the [ __ ] out
early
wasn't he his training guy he used to
hit his bar when he was born yeah he
used to spark together so he kind of
knew
what uh
he was old he was taking drugs that made
him lethargic yeah um
he should have never did it but i guess
by him doing that it would never been me
unbelievable the inspiration
what how old so your your you're 12
years old you see ali
from 12 at 14 you know you're going to
be heavyweight 14 i talked ali that's
what i was going to ask you so ali he
called you because of course
with their friend they know just yeah
this year
and one of the people that was with us
called
ali to talk because he wanted to talk
because about something
and first things i heard because why you
let that bum beat you like that oh i
started crying
when you became the heavyweight champion
yeah first phone call afterwards who did
you talk to
um you remember like milly wall
because his um
i don't know what he said
and
first person you talked to after you won
yeah what was it like when cuss passed
away like how did you handle when it
first happened when you got this
not good
did the focus go away that the well
intensified oh really
yeah
when you think so i would think so but
how did you manage that rage at that
point
like when you're going to that point now
how do you manage that rage because oh
know my whole objective is your total
surrender your total domination i'm
gonna destroy you
that's the mind that's why rogan said
when he watched you you were
intimidating you you know your rage is a
very unique rage to mike well that's
their fault to be intimidated that's
their fault to be intimidated yeah
wow
what an answer to get oh my god
that's their fault to be intimidated how
you listen i scare you for something you
worked for wow you have to give it to
him without a struggle
without a struggle you have to give it
to him
mike your wisdom is on a whole different
level man you say some stuff that you
you're like you know you're saying like
speaking you say something it's very
simple it's just it's um
whether it's whether they fail it's
elementary isn't it
i don't know about that you've lived
with a lot of people everybody here is
going to fight for what they love for
even they never had a fifth fight in
their life they're gonna fight
mike i'm sitting here i'm thinking hey i
wanna in a different industry okay i
wanna be the best of the best of the
best like you became a heavyweight
champion youngest ever if i wanna be the
best in my sport say this business what
tips would you give me i want to be i
want to be the best in our business this
business this is insurance they're
building their businesses but just the
mindset of wanting to be the best what
is the mindset you can transfer to
somebody being able to just find out the
first guy really really succeeded on
this [ __ ] probably 1900 or something
like that even if he was a crook
let's go from there
and go all the way there and read all
the way till you get to you
okay so once study history yeah study
study until it gets to you
and then you realize those people were
just you and funny clothes
okay so one
fantastic i gotta go study history
everybody that came before me what else
do i do
then you watch you you read everything
they did now you practice it now let's
see what this [ __ ] really works
can you can you teach desire or the
desire has to come from somebody
you can inspire desire
but can you teach it i don't know i
never had to try to teach anybody that
nobody had to teach you the fire because
you had it it was it was within you well
no it wasn't definitely within me you
know somebody had to bring it out and
show that i deserve to have what i could
have i've learned self-love
you know no i don't care how great you
are how much you succeed without
self-love you're nothing
because self-love is discipline
and discipline is doing what you hate to
do but do it like you love it
you know
why didn't it no i agree with you mike i
i totally agree with you
you've recreated yourself many times
you've reinvented yourself many times
what's the bible yeah well i know who
you believe actually you hear it so much
you really believe that i really don't
think you reinvented yourself you don't
think you've reinvented yourself no i
think all the people that wanted me to
be down is dead now
all the people that wanted you to be
those executives certain people
tax people this lady kept calling mike
you don't got anything to give us
it's the tackler you wouldn't let me um
wouldn't let me cut my back and then
they died and that they know i didn't
have to pay taxes and what they were
just busting my balls
i'm serious because eventually writing
taxes you don't pay a certain amount of
time like 10 years so i don't pay you
don't have no money okay my little cut
just so can you pay it now that not yet
so when it's down to like what 3 million
2 million i might be able to pay you now
you know if anybody had tax problems you
know they take it off you don't they
take little off you out here you just
gotta be patient oh you know it came
from 60 to like three just you just
half the room's not gonna not gonna pay
taxes for three years they're gonna be
like i'm gonna wait
i was surprised they didn't take my
house or take i was i was waiting for
them to take stuff and they didn't take
any i don't [ __ ]
mike
a lot of people have come in when they
see somebody winning you know charles
osnevour i don't know if you know he's
an armenian singer i saw him perform at
19 at 90 years old he said when i was
making money and coming up he says i was
married five times and i saw a lot of
people that acted like they wanted the
best for me but it was very hard to
realize at the end of the day there was
really only five people i can trust the
most because everybody wanted to kind of
take stuff from me how do you
differentiate the difference you know
between flattery and compliment mike
you're so amazing mike's you're this
what's flattery what's the compliment
you have to know who you are first okay
first you know you are
it depends if you want to be flattered
you know it's up to you you know
everybody knows you know i know who i am
people say the grades all the time you
this you that whatever they say i i know
who i am
you know
and i don't i that's who i am
i don't i flat a lot of people here i
can't say that yeah i do flatter a lot
of people
you flatter a lot of people yeah do you
listen so many great people you have to
sure
sure but flattery you know compliment
flattery and i guess the angle i'm
taking with this is
what what did you look at people to let
them into you meaning you know i like
this guy i trust him i'm gonna let him
in what was your formula to let people
in because the bigger you get you can't
let too many people in right so how do
you process who you let in who do you
keep out right
by knowing who to keep out
i don't know who do you keep out i'm
asking you i i'm a strong believer that
everybody you fight is not your enemy
and everybody helps you is your friend
you know
not everybody you fight is your enemy
and everybody that helps you is your
friend friend
not everybody who helps you is your
friend yes
mike your wisdom is on a different level
no because you you know you you put it
out there you're with them that
the question
the questions the the depth is the
question yeah
the answer just goes with the question
doesn't hold any more weight it just
goes with the deafness of the question
at this point where you are okay
what you're doing fighting are you still
enjoying watching fights are you still
enjoying watching boxing ufc absolutely
you do who do you like watching i like
watching all the fights i like watching
tango like tyson fury i like um and
devin haney i like um this young guy um
steven shakur there's a bunch of little
fighters they need to start fighting
each other now
is there a favorite weight class you
like to watch at this point or it
doesn't matter for you you just like to
see good fights exciting fights you got
it in ufc uh you like watching conor you
like watching
i like o'connor's number one yeah i like
them all connor's number one big fan
yeah
you think he's gonna make a big comeback
we normally get injury like that's tough
those are tough injuries
overcome
they continue to come back and you
continue doing the same thing kicking
you have to kick to win if you if you
don't you have the fear of possibly
breaking it again
so he made a lot of money if it's just
if it's money he has to do some other
stuff some announcements and some other
stuff
he's really advantageous
just be who he is he's gonna always have
something cool to do
he's always going to have something cool
to do yeah i saw the other post a
picture of a nice lambo yadi bot i don't
know if you saw that or not well i don't
know um if that means he's rich that mr
show they spend a lot of money
any advice for someone who's starting
because some of our guys are starting to
make a lot of money millions of dollars
but you know they got kids they got
families what advice would you give to
somebody that starts making a lot of
money money they've never made before
there's always some trust funds and
trust fund organization
from what i learned from all of the
robber barons say the turn of the
century 150 years ago rockefeller
wolfshell and before then like in saint
they might have been
500 of the families 1900 may have been 2
000 or whatever um
percentage families but now you've seen
their names they're still out but the
names are five percent you don't see too
many um those old guys you may say
rockefeller off to alabama you don't see
that now it's all about um
there's some silicon city money
but you notice on a certain well i was
trying to say
that mr art and taking care of money
because only a few of those guys that
were robbing barons back in the 1890s
and stuff like that only have a handful
still survive now
so normally the third or second
generation all that billionaire and
their money goes away
second third generation the billionaire
money goes because these guys don't work
hard for they don't understand
the bad guys did you hear what he just
said oh my god you know now these kids
know the value of everything but they
don't know they know the price of
everything but under the value of
anything you got to save money not spend
money i used to be got to spend money
all the time and then i said oh sick
when i didn't have it i wanted it now i
have it i don't want this [ __ ]
and that's what sometimes people have to
deal with they have to deal with
survivors remorse and all that stuff
everybody knows that she got shot died
of ods and i made it i'm big time i can
get anybody i want to do anything i want
who the [ __ ] do i think i am
you know
so it comes back to really i'm
submitting to god to the energy the
universe wow definitely that was
powerful my
top five in your opinion
i saw your interview i've seen your
interview with arsenio hall when uh i
think it's is it sugar ray and ali
it's so beautiful that interview the way
what he says about you what you say
about him you can tell there was a very
strong affinity between uh both of you
and uh you know muhammad ali talking
about the fact that this is the man he
doesn't want to fight and then him
saying i wouldn't be hawaiian without
you if you haven't seen it you got to
watch it top five greatest boxer of all
time in your opinion
that's it ali at the top
awesome well
mike uh i know many of us were looking
forward to you coming out as a guest how
many guys enjoyed this sit down with uh
tyson i
appreciate you so much for coming out
thank you again for agreeing to do this
brother appreciate it really enjoyed it
thank you this was great thank you
this has to be by far one of my favorite
interviews i've ever done in my life if
you enjoyed it as much as i had to give
it a thumbs up and i have two other
interviews that i think you like one of
them was with teddy atlas his former
train if you've never seen it click over
here and the other one is with buster
douglas the controversial victory over
mike tyson the first time he beat him if
you've not seen that click over here as
well take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you